JEREMY WALKER: Hi, my
name's Jeremy Walker.
I'm a developer
advocate here at Google,
and we are continuing
our conversation
on the three flaws
in software design
with Max Kanat-Alexander
from YouTube.
Now we're going to
cover flaw number two,
so do you want to
take it from here?
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER: Yeah, sure.
So this is the second part
in our four-part series
about the three flaws
of software design.
And our second flaw is not
making the code easy to change.
And you can call
this rigid design.
It's a system that's basically
too rigid, too difficult
to change.
And there are two ways
you can accomplish this.
One of them is design
in too many assumptions
about the future and the
other is writing code
without enough design.
I'm going to go into
what both of these
really mean and give examples.
So the first way to do this is
to make too many assumptions
about the future.
The traditional way that
people think about doing this
is the waterfall model, where
you do big design up front
and then you do big
development, and then
big QA, and then big release.
But the problem is that by the
time it gets to your users,
it doesn't really
match the requirements.
Ultimately, what this
means is that there's
been a failure to understand
that your requirements will
change.
So, what do I mean about that?
Well, you can do
it in a big way.
For example, I worked on
a product called Bugzilla,
which was a bug tracking system.
At the beginning of the
history of Bugzilla,
it was used only by
the Mozilla project--
the people who make Firefox now.
And it was only
used for the browser
and a few other projects,
small projects at the time.
They had about 100,000
bug reports in the system.
There was one
version field, where
you could say what version
the bug was found in,
and one target
milestone field, which
was the branch that you
expected the bug to be fixed in.
And there were no custom fields
because custom fields are evil.
In fact, supposedly--
this is actually
a joke in the bug tracker world,
that custom fields are evil.
There was a famous article
by Joel Spolsky about it
who also wrote a bug tracker.
Now the last time that I
was working on the Bugzilla
project, there were
10,000 installations
on almost every operating
system imaginable,
including HP-UX, AIX, and
things that you probably
haven't heard of or seen
or worked with in a decade.
Users need to track bugs
on multiple branches,
so they need to
know that it affects
multiple different versions.
And some projects need to
track millions of bugs.
Yahoo has a Bugzilla with
millions of bugs in it.
And Red Hat has a
Bugzilla installation
which has one component
for every single package
that you can install on
Red Hat Linux or Fedora,
a Red Hat [INAUDIBLE], which
is something like 80,000
or 90,000 components
in the system
that you can file bugs
against, because they all
have different owners.
JEREMY WALKER: Oh yeah, yeah.
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER: And we had
to add a custom field system.
It turns out that
not one bug tracker
fits all sizes of projects.
And Bugzilla is a
widely-used product,
but there are very few
developers who work on it.
It's about the size of maybe
a very small feature team
at most companies.
I would say that the amount
of effort that was on it when
I was last working
on it was maybe
about the total of three
full-time engineers,
and when I left we
had 1,500 open feature
requests against Bugzilla.
So the chance that its
requirements will change
is very high.
And so the problem was that
we had a lot of assumptions.
For example, that
it would only ever
run on one database
system, based
on our original requirements.
Or we had an assumption
that nobody would ever
need to track a bug
across multiple projects--
the same bug across
multiple projects.
But it turns out that many
people needed to do that.
And one of Bugzilla's
fundamental assumptions,
which is built into
its external APIs,
is that product
names are unique.
If you can file a bug
against a product, which
is a particular categorization,
then that name is unique
and our external API
depends on that fact
in a way that's almost
impossible to change.
So you can't have products
with the same name
and different sort
of classifications.
And having multiple
versions for the same bug
was very, very difficult
because of the way
it was designed originally.
And it turns out
that when you want
to cause people to install
a server product that
uses a database system,
they have a database system
and they're not going to
install a new one just
to install your product.
Particularly Oracle
shops don't want
to install MySQL
just for one product.
They want to use Oracle.
The developers before my
time had written raw SQL
all over the entire
application, so there
were 5,000 to
10,000 lines of SQL
throughout the application that
had to somehow be made generic
across-- and the
design of the system
depended, actually, upon
programmatically building SQL
queries.
So it was very difficult
to actually make
that work across
different systems.
We did, we did.
But it was a lot of work.
You can also do
this in small ways.
For example, when you use
a magic number instead
of a constant,
you're assuming-- you
just litter a number all
over the code base-- you're
assuming that number
is not going to change.
You might be right, but
you're probably wrong.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah, I've
run into that before.
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER:
You'll have people say,
we will never need to blah.
This is a danger phrase.
You hear people
say, we will never
need to have people outside
of our team see this code.
And then one day it
gets open sourced.
You'll say, we'll never need
to support newer standards.
Right?
People say, there will
never be an HTTP 2.0.
But it turns out there
is an HTTP 2.0 now.
Nobody would have-- I think
when HTTP 1.1 came out,
people were like,
we're done, it's fine.
One of the most dangerous
ones that people say
is, we will never need to
support international users.
This is very, very difficult
to bolt on to a system
after you've written a few
hundred thousand lines of code.
And there's infinite
numbers of things
that people can
say we will never
need to and be wrong about.
But, that doesn't
mean that you should
try to anticipate
everything because then
you also get into writing
code you don't need,
which was our previous flaw.
The way that you
handle it is you
design code based on what you
know now, and know for sure.
What you have actual,
factual data about,
not on what you think
will happen in the future.
Now, sometimes you know now
that internationalization
is difficult to add
on in the future.
So that's something
you know now,
but you don't know now that you
will need internationalization.
So the difference there
is that you add code
maybe to support
internationalization,
but you don't actually
add the whole framework
to actually do the
internationalization.
Maybe you add a minimal, minimal
layer that makes it possible,
or will make it easy to make
that change in the future
if you have to.
But you don't implement
a whole framework
that extracts all the
strings and sends them off
to translators and
everything because you
wouldn't need to do that.
So another way to
basically do rigid design
is to just not
design your codes.
Often you see spaghetti code,
which is just a long bunch
of if-else statements or
1,000-line method that just
sort of goes through-- if it's
spaghetti, it's a long string.
And you could even possibly
say the more you assume
things won't change, the more
your code becomes spaghetti.
Spaghetti is, of
course, hard to change
because you have
code duplication,
people are cutting and
pasting, it's very complex,
it's hard to understand what's
going on at any given point.
It's not safe to change.
You could introduce a bug or you
could introduce security holes
and not know.
It's funny because the more
spaghetti your code becomes,
the harder it
becomes to change it.
And so it actually sort of
becomes a compounding problem
or a vicious cycle where
it's not safe to change,
so nobody wants to change it,
so nobody wants to clean it up
and it just gets worse
and worse and worse.
I've worked on a lot of
code like this, actually.
A lot of the time
what people do is
they send me in to
fix things like this.
And you could possibly even
define spaghetti by the fact
there's code
duplication complexity
and it's not safe to change.
And the way that you solve this
problem, it's not that you say,
all code must be designed
perfectly all the time.
Instead you say, the
quality level of your design
should be proportional to
the length of future time
in which your system will
continue to help people.
Not every single system needs
to have perfect, amazing design.
You don't need to
sit around and think
about what should be
the class structure
for my five-line script that
I'm going to write as a hack
and I'm never
going to use again.
But if you think
that your system is
going to be used for a
reasonable period of time
in the future, and
you should assume
that it's going to be
used for much longer than
you think it's going to be used.
Because there's been a lot
of projects in the world that
were only going to be around
for six months, and then
ended up being
around for 10 years.
So you should err on the
side of a little more design
than you think is necessary.
But you don't need to
design it into infinity,
and not everything needs
to have amazing design.
You just need to consider
how many people am I
going to help in the future?
How long am I going to
help those people for?
And use that to inform
your design, basically,
or the quality level
of your design.
So that wraps it up
for our second flaw.
Any questions?
JEREMY WALKER: Well
I did have one.
Again, I read the book so I like
to lead into these examples,
but you gave a good example
of this in real life.
I think you've
already given some,
but I thought it'd be
good idea to point out
if you remember
the agency example.
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER: Yes.
So, I had a friend who worked as
a contractor-- and this is just
one example of many developers
that I've interviewed
and discussed this
sorts of things with.
His company was a contractor
to a particular agency,
and this agency had a
design for a system.
And the way that this
agency wanted to do things
was they wanted to write
a 300-page requirements
document before any
code was written.
JEREMY WALKER: Over a long
period of time, right?
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER:
Oh yeah, it took them
two years or something
to write this document.
And by the time the
document was actually
delivered to my
friend's company,
it was internally inconsistent.
It was very hard to understand.
It was extremely complex to
implement any piece of it.
And by the time
that they actually
got it out the door, which
was years and years and years
because they kept having
to clarify things,
it really wasn't relevant
to the requirements
of the actual users
at that time anymore.
This is sort of like
the ne plus ultra,
like the extreme of assuming
that your requirements won't
change.
You spend a five year process
before you release anything,
where you've designed some
incredibly complex system
and you're almost bound to fail.
Particularly because
a good test of truth
is throwing it against something
in the physical universe.
And so until you've sort
of thrown your software
against a user, you really
don't know if it's right.
And so waiting five years to
throw an idea against a user
means you have a lot of
wrong that you have to fix.
JEREMY WALKER: I
think you mention
in the book you shouldn't overdo
it by a lot-- you should only
go two months out at most,
or something like that?
Or was it less than that?
MAX KANAT-ALEXANDER: Bugzilla,
we released every six months,
but we would release development
versions as an open source
project continuously,
very frequently,
and also anybody could check
out our code from source
at any time and
report bugs to us.
So it really depends on
the framework you're in
and the type of
product you're writing.
But I would say, don't
look out any farther
than you're sure
you know the future.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
Well, that covers the
second of the three
flaws in software design.
Please join us for the
next video in the series.